[Applause]
well thank you very much for that ladies
and gentlemen it's a huge pleasure for
both of us to see you all some months
ago the spectator said to me that they
would like me to do an event and who
would I like to do it with and I said
I'm very used to doing events with my
enemies and spend rather too much time
with them and would like to spend the
evening with a friend and they said
anyone in particular I said first choice
Roger Scruton and a lot of things have
happened since we agreed to get together
with you all so Roger and I've known
each other for almost 20 years now and
we have a lot of things in common a lot
of common interests a lot of common
loves and pursuits and some common
enemies and we could shoot the breeze
for the whole evening but we don't want
to do that because this is an incredibly
serious time for our country for the
culture and specifically for
conservatism and so we want to cover as
much ground as possible tonight and I'll
say at the beginning that in this
conversation we'll there'll be three
things in particular that I wanted to
get to at least at some point before
will hopefully come to you for some
questions I wanted us to discuss the
meaning of conservatives and what it is
now what it is we're conserving I wanted
us to get on to one of the things which
is on all of our minds of the moment
which is how we can find a way to have
meaningful discussions about things we
need to talk about in an age of Twitter
and thirdly if we can get there to the
question that I think one might sum up
has this prevailing ethos in our time
where
harmlessness has been elevated into the
greatest virtue anyone should seek to
attain so let's start with conservatism
who's gonna say that we should start
with the last of those because
harmlessness is something that neither
you nor I have any hope of attaining
however yes conservatism I I suppose
that I've made my career out of the
futile attempt to define it and to make
it into an intellectually respectable
cause I was brought up of course in the
post-war period when ideas were in
fairly short supply in the conservative
movement and where socialism was being
propagated as the natural philosophy of
the human condition
so I set my mind to trying to define it
and of constantly come back to it even
though as you would know conservatism is
more an instinct than an idea but it's
the instinct that I think we all
ultimately share at least if we are
happy in this world it's the instinct to
hold on to what we love to protect it
from degradation and violence and to
build our lives around it and what that
thing is you know it's very varied but
it's for us now in in this country it is
at least the heritage of political order
and our way of doing things the natural
way of being in this country where we
belong and defending it as our home and
I think that is the ultimate root of the
conservative position and we all want
the Conservative Party I think to
represent that and the fact is less and
less seems to although I think there
most of the members of parliament would
like it too and we have to ask ourselves
why this is why has it always seemed to
be the losing side
I think it's the losing side in the
world of of intellectuals and and
perhaps in the media - because instincts
are hard to discuss and even harder to
defend you know if you're in the
business of repudiating things throwing
things away declaring your your
emancipation from your past you get an
audience pretty quickly and you easily
find things to say but if you're in the
business of trying to defend what is
your basic sense of belonging in this
world words quickly run out and you
don't know how to do it but nevertheless
when it comes to voting or making
decisions for the family and whatever
the instinct prevails and this is why in
the intellectual world the left is
always in the ascendant whereas in the
real world which I occasionally glimpse
there at the right is always the solid
basis on which people stand there's also
things that the everywhere you go the
left's always demanding exactly the same
things in lockstep I mean every country
I go to every continent in the world
there's always the same thing the left
is after the same set of demands in the
same order and conservatives are always
conserving something slightly different
in each place yes well obviously
different things that they are
threatened in different places I mean
you can't understand conservatism in
France if you don't understand the
extraordinary idea of the nation which
they have left horse as the object of a
kind of idolatry which is the thing that
steps in when everything else has failed
and even the left have to pretend to
adore it what's the explanation for the
situation we've always had in Britain at
least have had for a long time that
where conservatives parliamentary that
said people in the parliamentary party
they seem to find it incredibly
difficult to sustain their position in
public
quite often in Prior
they're quite bullish and then in public
they can do free market hmm and then you
see them starting to worry yes it's true
and I've always often asked myself this
and I suppose I felt that I was failing
them by not providing them those
clinching crisp arguments that they
could come out with on the political
stage and take the people with them but
the fact is it's very hard for people
who are rooted in instincts to be
gripped by ideas and they are so that
they will never take the people with
them and a suspicion of ideas there's a
suspicion of them too and you have to
acknowledge that the left are very
belligerent you know I acknowledge that
it's very hard to stand up and say that
actually I don't agree with you you know
because that's not the language of
political debate that's acknowledged on
the left and this is this connects with
of course what you were referring to
earlier the the difficulty of installing
a custom or a culture of discussion in
the place of one of mob violence like
not exactly violence but a but
hysterical unity around around slogans
you know that and I think you don't get
yeah I've often thought this that the
left is very good at slogans you know
march forward into the future you know
and if you think what a slogan would be
on the conservative side it would be
something like hesitate and it doesn't
work there it comes
no I I once saw an example of that that
were the only protests I've turned up to
I remember years ago and I was with a
friend of mine from Long Island few of
us and I can't even produce was but at
some point we sort all chanted something
and then we stopped we did it once and I
said to one of the friends when we're
not very good at this are we
and she said well Douglas we are view is
if you send something once that's quite
enough and and and that's the difference
of the difference of habit
I mean I don't want to keep saying the
same thing any more than you do it's
also though it goes to the heart of what
we think communication is you know if
you think of communication as a an
exercise in respect for the other you
don't repeat yourself repeating yourself
suggest that you're either demented or
all that you you just don't care about
the other person's response you're
prepared to override it and say the same
thing again and again there's no there's
no way in which a chanted slogan invites
an answer no and I think that's there's
a whole politics of that kind which
grows out of the mass movements on the
left but also invades the language of
the left both of us at different times
in different ways have come across this
problem of the fact that it seems to
have become at least increasingly
difficult to hold on to truths in public
to defend them I've often thought this
is something to do with V suddenly it's
been exacerbated by the modern media
where everything is everything is one
person away all the time so that the
consequence of every statement can be
put right before you and so that people
can hold on to very abstract ideas often
but find it hard hard to hold onto
concrete ones in public and then hardest
of all riskiest of all to be at all
involved in the pursuit of truth for its
own sake yes that's of course as we know
various people have argued that we live
in a post truth society and point to
obviously quite vivid examples like
President Trump has as it as
illustrating this
but you know there is no such thing
actually as post true thinking truth is
fundamental to out that so the idea of
thought that that's what thinking is at
the attempt to get the true answer to
something so if you if you discard truth
there is nothing left except the pursuit
of power which means shouting as far
high as in a high as tone as you can and
and I think this is one thing that
University students have to confront in
in the humanities this this idea that
truth is some doubt how marginal or
negotiable there isn't an absolute
standard but it's simply what you can
something that you use to embarrass your
arguments is that you put flowers around
their necks you know that that is
something that is preached by many of
the gurus whom people study in
particular Michel Foucault who was so
influential still is in forming the new
curriculum the new curriculum is not
about finding out the truth of what
people have written but finding the
power that advances behind it so that
you can confront it and be a hero of the
left I have to say I'm I'm amazed by the
the move that's been done on this for
the post truth thing because the people
who complain about Donald Trump and
others as being post truth and they've
got a point of course but they are the
very people themselves who pulled down
the whole concept of truth every
philosopher they admire deconstructed
the idea of truth for decades yes and at
the very least they enjoyed it or went
along with it they never opposed it and
this is one of the things in your book
the thinkers of the new left you expose
yes that's that's absolutely true and of
course exposing that doesn't do much
good because there isn't any way of
exposing the fraud fraudulence of
someone if he really is fraudulent but
he's lost the capacity to perceive that
you know and I think the
institutionalized fraudulence is part of
what we encounter in universities if you
see these denunciations such as we've
seen
recently of the that statistician in in
Cambridge who claimed who came up with
the wrong research of you know Noah Karl
he's called
you know that these and these
denunciations are not founded upon any
respect for truth they are founded on
the associations of people with up with
the wrong thing yes adjacency it now all
right it's not enough you have bad views
you were standing adjacent to something
manifestation of adjacency who comes off
West but it's by the way I was your
instigation for something I'm writing at
the moment I was I finally went back and
read some of the texts that I felt I
should have done many years ago I write
finally red food color last you know and
I have to say I I'm so appalled still I
mean I'm a bit of a pub or on this
actually because I had I I'd read about
it I'd heard about it I'd always known I
sort of instinctively sighted disliked
it but the catastrophe of what he does
the sort of perversion of all life
it's brilliant of course and filled with
resonant phrases and so on but this
perversion of of life as being solely
about power yes and the ignoring of
every other human insincerity total
ignoring of love the total ignoring of
forgiveness power only power and you
need to find where it is squeeze it out
of those people and drink up some of the
juice yourself and that this has been
imbibed by now a couple of generations
of students absolutely it fuels all the
causes of the day because yes whatever
the cause is feminism or or
transgenderism or whatever it is about
emancipating an oppressed group from the
domination of the oppressor and this
might be exactly the wrong way of
looking at it you know I personally
the emancipation of women in the
political sphere is obviously a great
benefit to them but to think that they
should be emancipated from man as such
you know and to undermine that the
relation between the sexes in that way
is as you say putting power in the place
of love and we it's one of the hard
things again for going back to your
original question about defining and
defending conservatism it's very hard to
propose a philosophy that is based on
love rather than on resentment or hatred
because love is a personal thing that
you don't want to talk about you don't
want to put it on display and if you do
so it sounds you know Kitsch sentimental
it doesn't have the right political feel
where as hatred and resentment there's
the sense that that things are being
that you're being excluded from things
that things are oppressing you and must
be must be torn down that is an easy
thing to form into a political movement
then either and I suspect this is part
of what makes it so difficult to express
conservatism in public some forms of
love I mean I agreed nobody wants people
to get to a key in in public but but
some forms of love people have I think
very welcoming to at least some people
are two people expressing it love of
country it's it's tricky there's
definitely places youyou wouldn't do it
not in a university no no no
but I mean I I've wondered often about
this with thee I mean resentment is is
you say such an incredibly strong tool
yeah it's an unbelievably strong strong
weapon to bring to the fight and one of
the things just returning them quickly
to this issue with conservatism it
always strikes me is that is that we do
have equal weapons hmm it's just that
nobody wants to wield them I think an
example I've given to you in private
before is that I've often thought that
there's almost as if both political
sides have as it were a box of dangerous
things that that they know they can call
upon they know they can open it and use
if needed with a hammer break this in
case of political emergency and the left
have obviously resentment class hatred
and many other forms of resentment and
they are pulling it out they're letting
things off that seeing flares go off
sometimes they go and take somebody out
and they don't apologize and then then
some and they have got total run of
their box and on the right there is a
box of useful things which again can go
wrong but but may also be the thing you
need most if you're going to win any
political fight and it's it's chained
it's covered in a rug we pretend it
isn't there and yet it would seem to me
that the thing most obviously in that
box is this is precisely this love of
country love of society love of the
things you have not wanting to change
them unrecognizably or carrying out a
political experiment for a Nirvana you
haven't quite imagined yet and and and
we do have that and just a final thought
on that I may which is it you know I
might be breaking a confidence now but
he'll why not but I mean I was at I was
recently at something with a
Conservative MP and somebody asks a very
good question of this conservative they
pointed to somebody in the room who was
it was a dinner and somebody was serving
some wine and somebody pointed to this
young man said how old are you
he said 24 and this person said do you
own a house said no do you think you'll
ever own a house said no and into your
tenses politicians said so what do you
say to him very good question very
pertinent question for everyone
the response was fine it was brownfield
sites folk featured prominently in the
answer and I just could have wept
because as I said to this person
afterwards you know the left is coming
at us with everything they have and
you're giving us brownfield sites that's
not going to do it the left is promising
him everything if he votes for them and
you're offering him this possibility of
a huge mortgage at some point in the
future way out of town who's gonna win
but we do have things yes oh the
particular issue in question is one
about which I'm quite an expert now yes
I would say that there is a clear answer
to the housing crisis which is to build
more beautifully so that people cease to
object and then you can build anywhere
nobody would object if you builds bath
again in the middle of the countryside
but that would require first of all
[Applause]
it would require an ongoing battle
against the architects volume builders
and all the vested interests that align
themselves behind them but if that could
be done and let's face it it was being
done and until this fatal discovery that
there was a conservative in the midst of
it if before we get on to the nature of
that fatal discovery and what is the
problem with the house building on this
because you spent many months looking
into it you spent a lifetime thinking
about architecture and aesthetics but
what were the main things that struck
you in the months you had dedicated
solely to this well the first of all
that because we have an adversarial
planning system in which all people can
take part and raise their objections
which is a very healthy thing
democratically it we also have the
consequence that those who have most to
lose from a new development or think
they have most to lose will get gang up
against the developers and so we have a
massive resistance to the building of
new housing schemes from people whose
amenities and environment will be taken
away by them because so much of what is
built now on especially in the centers
of our towns you know the the square
cube the cubes of glass that are
dropping everywhere these things not
just hateful to people but they are
destructive of their sense of home they
make real places into non places and
that's what's happening in all our
developments and the reason being that
things are not designed as places
there's there are economic reasons for
this
there are stylistic reasons and there's
a general growth of ignorance about what
architecture really is architecture is
means the building of a genuine home a
place where you can belong and and you
can't belong in a place if others don't
there too so so the solution is to make
places and not drop little boxes
everywhere or glass cubes in the towns
and we have so many examples of places
all our old towns are lovely places
where people want to be there's no
reason why they couldn't be it couldn't
be done again and that's that would be
the answer
people would after LC yes of course we
can't object and more and more people
recognize that the that we shouldn't
object to providing housing for the
people who haven't got it so there is a
solution and but it requires
confrontation with vested interests like
everything else and an awful lot of
those vested interests connected to the
conservative conservative party it has
to be said individuals or the parties
well that's a great question I hadn't my
investigations were cut peremptorily
short because you could you continue in
a minute independent is something that
might be the right solution sort of
brings us naturally on by the way to I
think it's the first time you've done
anything in public since this all broke
can I just ask I mean both of us are
pretty private people in all sorts of
ways but what was it like having them or
they actually just come right at you
well it was horrible I mean because
there's no holds barred you know it's I
was reminded actually of of the theory
that Juha Rene Johar the French
philosopher an anthropologist produces
to explain the the scapegoat phenomenon
his view is that in the heart of every
society there are these huge tensions
caused by the fact that others have what
you want essentially and that you've
been excluded from from what you deserve
etc these tensions build up and they've
been building up in our society as we
know radically recently because of the
remain lever conflicts and all that
and there is a need for the victim to
persecute when that happens you single
him out and it's necessary that he
should be innocent if he's actually
guilty of something then you can't pour
all your venom into him so here he is
the the lamb led to the slaughter and of
course we have the great example in
Christ whose crucifixion would have
meant nothing if he weren't actually
innocent and the pursuit of the
scapegoat of juha is the way in which a
society relieves itself of this burden
of mutual resentment growing within it
and you feel that I mean I'm not going
to compare myself with that obviously
with Christ and all the great people who
and all the real scapegoats of the past
but if you look back at it you can see
in a small way how this process emerges
if it has to single out a victim I have
singled myself out by having the
impertinence to defend the conservative
worldview you know that makes me a
natural victim and most of the people
who who who want to attack me would not
have had the the patience to read
anything that I've written all the
ability probably
but nevertheless social media provide
them the these people who ought not to
have a voice with a voice and there they
are at it I don't look at the social
media but but unfortunately politicians
do and this is a new thing to me you
know every every school teacher knows
that that we that children ought to be
told to leave their phones outside the
classroom yeah but nobody tells the
politicians to leave their phones
outside Parliament and but so they're in
there attached to these screens and
which only soundbite some words of
passing and the great thing about the
Twittersphere is that that he's it's
words that have picked out most of the
people who are attacking me is he from
what I heard we're attacking words I've
reused and I didn't you use this word
and of course that's what happens when
people are incapable of formulating a
whole sentence there was a there was a
moment when when the mob first came
through unsuccessfully last was a doctor
when your appointment was announced and
there's a very forgettable labor front
bencher called actually it's gone it's
he's called and drew something like this
anyhow he's low-grade even for the
talent on the bench that he's on and he
said at one point he said somebody had
put to him a few things that you said
and he said that somebody with your
views I think he said had no place in
modern society and I thought this was an
overreach even for them and pointed out
that in future we're gonna have to go to
the labor front bench for its views on
Hegel and Kant and Spinoza and we're
gonna be in trouble but but but there is
this there is this extraordinary thing
had happened with the unfortunate young
who is your interviewer for the New
Statesman on that hit job piece and it
happened with the labor front bench and
others which is instead of regard
instead of regarding books as being a
very good way for instance to work out
what their author thinks you can skip
that stage and go straight to thee you
don't even have to get to the word it's
worse than the word now now you have the
dog whistle you know there are words
which used to mean one thing but now I
mean a different thing if you hear them
in a particular tone that everyone else
can't hear but I'm going to interpret to
you by hearing it in a particular way of
course if you do hear the whistle you're
the dog but they haven't worked that bit
out yet so it's it's a shortcut to
everything but one of the things around
we get onto this is I mean this is
causing the deracinated of public
thought as well as public life it's why
we have people in politics like this
eminently forgettable labor front
bencher and I might say I'm sure you
wouldn't the conservative minister who
dispense with your services without
bothering to read what you'd said it's
it's
it's it's what it's why we've got them
but I'm I'm less concerned about them
than the fact that the thing that has
produced them is still going on this
this bit and I mean it was I think it
was we were both in Cambridge the other
month with John Peterson and I think it
was Jordan who mentioned then this this
issue about harmlessness because this
does seem to be in politics and in
everyone's life the great aspiration to
live your life as a harmless individual
to harm nothing and no one to say
nothing with the language you use to
express no ideas and to die having
harmed nothing and it's just it seems to
me an extraordinary aspiration yes well
to me you are completely harmless does
this I you know I've always thought so
yes I I can't but the point is it's not
just harmlessness that's being
recommended but the advertisement of
your harmlessness and now that's
something you would never do you know so
showing confronting the world with this
self-consciously harmless posture is
actually a form of narcissism yes it's a
it's saying love me I'm you know I'm you
have nothing to lose
and keep your distance don't aggress you
know etc so it's a it's it's a way of
proceeding through the world surrounded
by a cocoon of self love and that's an
easy way forward but of course it
involves renouncing the things on which
the value of life really depends namely
giving to others going out to others
taking risks in order to in order to
engage with them with real in real ways
of which love is won and indignation
another and so on it's a so as a
complete corruption of the relationship
between I and you you know everybody
becomes a neutral it and this harmless
thing drifting through the this
the sphere of mists and I that is all it
has a deep cultural significance it's
not for you or for me to do anything to
change this except to set an example
you know to say look that life can be
quite different from that it can be
interesting and exciting it can involve
the giving of your things to others and
if you give to others you receive from
them you know there's a whole world out
there and all you have to do is turn
away from that dark corner where your
red lone with your screen and look out
of the window you know and I think this
is one of one of the problems that
people are forgetting that that there is
a real meaning to life and that is in
the relations with others I think going
back to what you were worrying about
there the collapse of public discourse I
remember the time when people on the
Left wrote books and we criticized them
and we wrote books and they criticize
them and sometimes we have meetings
together where we discuss them it was
wonderful and you know actually this it
still goes on one member of parliament
John cratis they remember has written a
very interesting book from a sort of
revised William Morris Marxist viewpoint
on our society in the old labor way and
I attended all the meetings where we
discussed this because he was the kind
of mind which it should reflect some
things which recognizes that opposition
is not a negative thing it's the it's
the positive thing from which further
understanding grows and if all our MPs
were like that and I think some of the
Conservatives like that Jesse Norman is
like down for instance we would be able
to revive the culture of public
discussion but as I say it means they
should leave their phones outside
Parliament you can't have it you can't
the think it seems to me if anyone's
ever tried it even though even in a room
of three people if if there's one person
who will not allow
thought to go in a particular direction
even if it's true then the others can't
do it either
yes and if you live in a society where
one person in the wild can claim that
right then which may be where we are it
becomes even it becomes him almost
impossible that is true but I think one
should also remember that that there are
many historical precedents for this you
know look back to the 17th century and
the Puritan sort of revivals in our
country you'll realize that those were
times when the wrong word meant death
and there's plenty of parts of the world
where that still is the case and the
default position of human beings is
orthodoxy because orthodoxy is safe you
know you have to ask yourself why are
heretics so so fiercely punished you
know it's not that the real opponent who
is followed who's punished the person
from some other religion or somehow
outside them the tribe so to speak it's
the person who agrees with you about
everything it's set to one little detail
you know whether the sign of the Cross
should be made with two fingers or three
it's in there Russian Old Believers
catastrophe you know these these things
go deep in our social nature and as just
the the scapegoating phenomenon and we
should always remember that and be aware
of it we must find a way not to provoke
it but still to create that sphere of
free discussion which is which is
protected from it that's what we had in
this country since and that's what the
Enlightenment gave to Europe as a whole
that's ability to create a sphere of
free discussion in which we could
actually consider our ABAB problems
rationally and find a solution to them
but as you know there's so many of our
problems today where one side has
monopolized the language so so a
heretical thought becomes inexpressible
and this was beautifully
caricature advice by all well in 1984
but you know I was just reading an Oscar
in a French Journal about the way in
which macarons speeches all conformed to
the to the syntax of 1984 part of this
of course you've just will come out the
ordered set up in a minute but a part of
this is what you've just described
though the legacy that we have had in
this country which some of us are very
proud of this legacy of free thought
free expression allowing certain amount
of heresy these are these are parts of
tradition you can be proud of or you can
wish to repudiate and you you coined the
term some time ago the culture of
repudiation and elegantly sums up
precisely this thing where everything
everything you've inherited is what you
are against it was put to me a few days
ago by a young woman in Germany I was
speaking in Berlin who said this is a
nice way of putting it she said everyone
of my generation travels to the Far East
to see lots of temples but I never see
them at our cathedrals and I said of
course this is it's an oddity this this
desire to go all the way around the
world but never never to pay attention
to what's yours in front of you right on
your doorstep you never see people doing
holidays around the cathedrals of Europe
in their gap years which is odd when you
think about it because why wouldn't they
I mean I'm not saying it's an either/or
but it's strange to go to Siem Reap if
you've never been to Chartres yes III
think though there is obviously this
culture of repudiation all around us and
if that's all there was we would feel
despair but I actually think that there
is also an empathic impulse to renew
which is in everybody
you see this with young people who go to
for instance to study in Oxford or
Cambridge how keen they are to join the
College Choir how they actually enjoyed
the atmosphere of the hall and the
formalities and the sense of belonging
to a continuous tradition and adding to
it I think there are many such
institutions in our country still they
are denigrated of obviously by a lot of
people but people are instinctively
drawn to them and I think those are the
sort of things which should provide the
Conservatives with their major causes
and if you ask why young people join the
military for example is partly for this
sort of reason the desire to affirm
something and to belong to something we
should just make that more available
than it is that feeling and you find
this in America that feeling is widely
available of course as you know it's not
available in universities but there is
some hope that universities will close
down soon rival forms of education will
be blown in there in their place you
know if there were a little college in
the center of London which I was master
and you Dean you know fine yes we were
very soon have a you know a little
assembly of somewhat bewildered people
whom we were taking the hand and you
know and it would grow and it would not
be a university it would be something
which as was founded in the Middle Ages
when the monasteries first got going you
know people need those communities
outside the family but inside society
which take on the business of education
the business of passing on our culture
the business of creating art music
poetry so it was wonderful what happened
then not everything was good of
but it was a spontaneous birth of
something which made a civilization and
there's no reason why it shouldn't
happen again no and there are as you
said the there are positive signs in
American Academy where I think of the
three main universities in America which
had major scandals over what might now
call woken us familiar with this term
now they're all suffering admissions
problems as a result Brett Weinstein's
former University evergreen ever since
they chased him and his family off
campus for doing nothing wrong they
they've they've got terrible admissions
problems Middlebury College since
Charles Murray
it was meant to speak and the female
professor who was with him was
physically assaulted and hospitalized
Middlebury's gotta have having to having
to accept it's got fewer people applying
this year than before and so I said I
would say the these were the harsh bit
of this but which must be pushed is that
these people must realize that there is
a price to pay for not educating people
yes and that there is no reason why an
American family should remortgage their
house to send their son or daughter away
to become stupider and
but as you say the positive bit of that
is that we have it's not as if we're
starting from year zero no but this is a
very important point though we need the
freedom to create new institutions and
that's where the danger lies you know
that for instance in this imaginary
college that you and I could set up
tomorrow we could produce a degree
course in Western culture which
everybody would love to take and we
could and we could then go on to to give
degrees but those degrees would not be
ratified you know they would we would
need a Royal Charter to provide them and
the Royal Charter would have to come
through all the apparatus of ignorant
lefties who control these things so you
wouldn't only if so there's a freedom
that we wouldn't have and I say this
because I'm part of Buckingham
University which has of course had a
huge difficulty in getting off the
ground precisely because there was a
pressure political prejudice against it
such a place could not be educational if
it was not teaching the standard Marxist
doctrines so one of the one of the worst
things about about this case you just
mentioned in Cambridge in recent days
with this young researcher who's been
dispensed with by the college was the
fact that the justification that the
students had for wanting him to go was
that they found his research offensive
and I mean my own research is of course
the truth is often offensive usually and
the idea but I thought that the the idea
that the first time a university had
thought that offending somebody was a
reason to therefore ruin somebody's
career and get rid of them
was an unbelievably ominous I mean this
remember though that there's this great
distinction between giving offense
and taking offense and we're living in a
culture where people become experts in
taking offense even when it hasn't been
given you know and that that's what is
taught in Gender Studies yes
it teaches young women to take offense
at every remark a man might make or even
his being there you know and it's a it's
a wonderful theatrical thing to change
offense but it doesn't lead any lasting
relationships at the Scouten Murray
College it will be illegal to take
Gender Studies because this is the
problem with a lot of these so-called
social sciences they're not Sciences
they're not they're not actually a
discipline it's just a political
indoctrination to make people bitter
they were when they went in however now
we are going to have to go to the
audience at some point but it can I just
before we do suggest that we if the
people with microphones are available
with the microphones already what I
suggest we do is that I point to people
and we take maybe two or three and ago
yes carry on talking yeah and the
strength of that yes exactly so we don't
need the lights up but just vaguely make
sure use of a wave meaningfully and I'll
maybe we'll take some there since
there's a microphone near there anyway
and could I just remind you I'm not
saying this just to be offensive but I
always like to stress that questions and
not autobiographies and they're usually
one sentence with a question mark at the
end thanks very much for your talk I
feel like I've quite a good idea of what
a conservative domestic policy is but
I'd like to hear your thoughts because I
think the two of you might possibly even
differ on what you'd consider a
conservative foreign policy to be good
and near that gentleman maybe some
hi there good to see you again Roger I
know you're going to Brazil in maximun
wonder will you want kind of message or
you bring into a zoo as you know we all
axes and I'm sorry I'm I'm Brazilian but
it was not my fault you know that we
elected the first conservative president
ever so what what kind of message do you
bring into Brazil thank you it's the
important question but maybe we'll have
one other thread to this makes a
gentleman behind with a piece of paper
in the air I was once a Conservative
member of parliament I was also an army
officer I'd like to ask whether you've
had any apology from James broken shower
or mr. Mercer or mr. Chouhan - you must
now understand that they fired you on a
completely full steer but behave quite
disgracefully have you heard anything
from anybody
what a good question
[Applause]
well I might as well take that last
question leaving Brazil to me I think
white seems fair
no I have had a very nice letter from
from Tom two gunas yes he has written
yes which was apologetic and I replied
to it in the same friendly spirit I was
I'd ever read what he said because I
don't look at that stuff
obviously I've had no apology from mr.
Mercer and the my relations with broken
sharra complex to say the least
I say there has been no apology there's
been a letter explaining in some way but
but you know I wrote back to that and
said no that's not really adequate so I
would like I wait for an apology but I
don't expect to get one because
apologies are very costly they require
you to see yourself from outside and
cast judgment on yourself and most
people find that very difficult so I've
given up on and you know I'm putting any
pressure but I think it is it would have
been right to apologize because it would
have helped me but for one thing I would
have survived very much more more
readily if that that was publicly known
and they would then be clear that he did
that extraordinary modern political move
of saying that he thought things could
have been done better I can never
understand why why they don't rise
there's a difference between that and
saying sorry
well they've had been shot that would
have been much more effective yes
yes I did think of sorry I'm a buttock I
think Peter Hitchens made a fantastic
point in the mail on Sunday a couple
weeks ago and writing about your case
when he said about mr. took and how to
mess he said that neither of them
neither then pass up an opportunity to
remind us of their military service aviv
Hitchens said I've met braver pacifists
well I don't think Brazil this platform
to any great people no no the message
I'll be taking you're so much nicer than
I am do it all night I I've lived longer
than you this is the message I our take
to Brazil is some make sure I get on
that plane to get back in and meanwhile
see a bit of the country and not saying
a thing that can be miss reported on
social media and and just be myself now
whether I can be myself in that climate
I don't know we'll see I know that that
I have a lot of fans in Brazil all my
books get translated into Portuguese and
you know that suggests that it's not a
very normal place and that there must be
some deep existential crisis going on
but whether I can satisfy that crisis I
don't know and foreign policy yes you're
right myself and we it would be hard to
know where the difference might be
unless we thought of a sort of concrete
example it's hard to say what a
conservative foreign policy would be at
the moment my own view is that it
wouldn't be for instance ring-fencing
international aid spending and not the
military budget it seems a very strange
thing to do but it has to be a sort of
case-by-case basis I'd have thought
and on intervention well again it
depends where yeah I would say that that
our foreign policy towards Europe is
misguided that it's it is taking Germany
and France as the principal parties to
be appeased and negotiated with whereas
our friends are in Eastern Europe I
think we have a we need a much more
positive approach to to those countries
in order to help them to build
themselves up for our own good too
because after all they're all fleeing to
us and we can't cope with the with the
overweight of population in our country
and I think many would want to go back
and build up those countries Poland
especially and Hungary
these are places which are essentially
deeply friendly to us in the way that
Germany and France never will be and
they are the way of balancing the
European Union's centrist policy making
it more friendly to the cause of
national identity
let's let's go over this side a lot of
hands and where's the microphone yes
just grab the first person what he's
given mic for in any way hi
I'd imagine most of our MPs are most of
our Conservative MPs and the Prime
Minister would disagree with very little
of what's been said tonight so while
they trying to achieve by pretending
that there's a difference between
themselves and and the TV up there good
and nearby just somebody on the other
side of the aisle maybe or a few roads
back yeah hello I'm interested in the
future of conservatism I have a 17 year
old son who is not left thinking and
what do you say to him who could be your
future our future about standing up to
ideology and well his rock stars to
bring forward in front of his friends
good question and whoever you see hi I'm
a 16 year old student and I like to say
that I'd be the first to join your
scrutiny college fasting
is there is there any hope that you
could offer me if I would like to go to
university to study the humanities or is
there no hope whatsoever right dolly do
you want to do with these firstly maybe
I'll leave em peas to you I think that
their aim is is to get by in office
without anyone noticing they're
conservatives and and I have to say let
me give you one very concrete example of
that I think I wrote this in spectator
the other week but you know when Labour
were in power they put people who were
left-wing in every single public body in
this country they're still there they're
still there like if not even like
snipers up the trees after a treating
army it's just they are still holding on
to the terrain and by comparison after
will soon be nine years of majority
conservative rule in this country some
people point to the success of William
Shawcross having been twice appointed to
the Charity Commission and then there
was a second success with Roger Scruton
being appointed to the building
beautiful Commission and and that's sort
of what they've got to show for public
appointments after nine years in office
and I think that tells you an awful lot
that they tend to say oh well
conservatives don't put themselves
forward for these appointments well they
should make it easier for conservatives
to put themselves forward for such
appointments it should not be the case
still that if you go to almost any
public institution in this country you
find someone who once wrote speeches for
Tony Blair or Robin Cook leading it and
I'm afraid that is still the case and
that tells you an awful lot about the
actual lack of ideological commitment of
some of the MPs very quickly I mean I
mean the two questions on that there is
hope absolutely and there are all the
things we've said about them some
extraordinary universities in this
country still with extraordinary
portions and departments within
great individual lecturers and I think
that here as in America you have to find
them out and just research beforehand
whether you're going to find somebody
who's really going to inspire you and
give you access to this whole world I
mean Alan bloom I think once said your
university years are your Charmed years
they stand between the years of
ignorance and the intellectual wasteland
most people go into an adulthood and and
so you don't want to waste these years
you tick you don't have waste them being
political you want to have the best
opportunity that culture will ever have
to get to you or you to it and it is
there you just have to choose and see
your way through carefully which goes
the same question the lady asked about
her son I mean he probably will if he's
not left-wing now he probably will be
for a bit but he may like me spend a
matter of hours on the left and be over
it by lunchtime so and there are lots of
- I mean it's not as if just now about
living and dead so many people to read
to look up to to absorb this number
leave of inheritance of things to know
about and it's not repudiated I totally
agree with that and one shouldn't
disparage all the universities just
because the vociferous part of them is
so difficult but obviously you have to
look around both my children are at
Oxford and loving it and and it doesn't
seem to be taking away the fragments of
knowledge that I sent them there with
and it might even be adding to them so
you know I'm pretty I'm content with
that
maybe the middle bit
oh no maybe we'll go to the back you
okay huh and there's an audience
uprising at the back yeah I'm gonna be
seeing Bogle a conservative MEP
candidate for Northern Ireland Sir Roger
first for me I may I add I think was
absolutely disgraceful the way you were
hounded out off government off your
position by literally a Twitter mob
talking up Twitter I get a stream of
abuse literally every day on Twitter
calling me things from house negro to
Tory houseboy to variety of other things
from from leftists engaged in identity
politics now I came to this country as a
nature as an immigrant and I made it my
own and it made me her own what do you
have to say about politics of identity
question maybe somebody else at the back
or two other people at the back maybe
one of the people there's a lady with a
yellow thing on waving vociferously and
right at the bag yes thank you
a man but it's yellow I got the color ID
I'm I'm reassured by your recognition of
my voice thank you if I said yes madam a
you spoke indeed indeed and I'm not
saying hasn't happened before
but anyway so Roger I just want to ask
you one question why why did you call
Douglas harmless gosh that one person
else nearby there yeah teach I teach as
a music college in London my students I
love them but they are all terribly woke
and left-wing now they get their news
feed not from newspapers or the
spectator but from their Google newsfeed
most of this is the BBC and the Guardian
the right wing news media if I
I hardly like to call the spectator
right-wing is it's just sensible and the
good thing about the spectator you have
opposing points of view it has a paywall
and this seems to me I wonder whether
you'd agree this is a problem they just
never hear an opposing view and they've
learnt their dogma their catechism of
woken us off by heart yes I can feel the
obviously there's a great agreement
about with that let me just take these
questions one after so they're obviously
addressed to me I'm question about
identity and actually politics I agree
that there is a there is something wrong
with identity politics as we now
perceive it what seems to be wrong is
that people sees an oppositional
identity always say I am this thing
whatever it might be transgender woman
anything with which I oppose the rest of
you you know I'm standing for that
against you all and they don't they
don't take hold of the the identity that
would reconcile them with others as you
have done beautifully as an immigrant
said I'm adopting the identity of this
country that has taken me in and which I
warm towards and that is what we should
be putting in the place of identity
politics the real identity the identity
that we share rather than the one that
puts it at lager us at loggerheads with
each other and I think there again it
goes back to what we were talking about
earlier resentment is so much easier
than love you know love requires you to
forgive the faults of the other to be
giving and forgiving
whereas hatred has no cost at all and
that's what we see on me in these
Twitter storms and so on and that's why
I say that Douglas is harmless because
you know however much he is an edge on
poverty
he's actual nature as I know it's one
that is founded on this respect for
others and this desire to belong with
others and to negotiate and discuss with
with them it's a so you have a
ultimately a conciliatory nature which
has been as it were bullied into
aggression by people who don't share
that with you so that's why I say
Douglas is harmless of course I don't
want him to be harmless all the time in
fact he's being great in fighting on my
behalf on the woke students in the music
college this is a real problem because
of course one of the things that that
that sparked off in me the real sense of
belonging to a civilization and a
culture to which I owed everything was
music and the same was true for Douglas
I'm sure and my music master at school
and my piano teacher and all those that
were immersed in this culture and it was
a form of of belonging which again was
harmless because it was part of the this
the culture all around which embraced
everyone and it it changed my mind and
my emotions and everything to be
immersed in our musical tradition in the
way that I have been and unfortunately
young people today however musical they
may be are not brought up with that
sense of immersion in a in a public
musical culture that has endured down
the centuries it's much more the the
slightly the aggressive backdrop of the
pop song which has been standard
standard fare so I think that that
doesn't help them to find an an identity
of belonging to the larger community
it's not that that's not the whole story
of course and it but and this is one of
the things I'm sure ever in this room is
worried by how do we bring young people
generally
to recognize that the world is greater
than the narrow and and ever more narrow
little sphere which wish their screens
aren't shepherding them into just add to
that I mean bring two of those together
that the site what I said the young lady
at the front that of course if if young
people aren't introduced that to this in
school if they don't for instance know
what the greatness of the musical cannon
is or literary can and then it's highly
unlikely they are going to of their own
volition discover it in adulthood it's
the best it might not be the only chance
but it's certainly the best and of
course they can discover a lot of the
other things including the pop culture
that that's gonna come anyway which is
why it's always so soul destroying when
you discover a music teacher teaching
the pop songs the children because that
means they're not gonna get to bar and
they're gonna miss everything that will
come from it
and I think one of the saddest things
for me at anyway it's what I describe as
the you know the politicization of
everything is the politicization almost
increasingly of yards if you if you'd
listen to Radio 3 now everything
everything is being played through the
feminist lens at the moment they keep
stressing you know the this this this
soprano role is sung by a woman it's all
it's a woman's role and a strong woman
has to say and so on I said wasn't yes
no we get it we get it and then you have
these strange intrusions of woken us
into into into the arts you know the the
problems insisting on a 50/50 gender
equality of composers by I think 2021 or
something and and then the Guardian
running a piece the other day about
their terrible whiteness of the British
poetry scene you think the British
poetry seems not like such a dominant
patriarchal rampaging or entity that it
deserves this additional decimation by
identity politics
anyhow maybe if we have any sonnet ears
they can speak up now
maybe this roughly this Bank here I was
wondering to what extent do you think
conservatives can make common cause with
those on the left to emphasize more
well they might call communitarian
instincts who value localism community
civil society people have the sort of
blue labor movement if you want to call
it that and therefore see conservatism
as something which isn't just a
left-right issue but can be sold across
that traditional divide very good
question somebody else nearby yeah the
the title of this conversation is the
future of conservatism do you think that
the future of conservatism in the UK now
is outside of the so-called Conservative
Party
and a-one more equally terrible question
there's a gentleman there waving I have
been out a great problem and finding any
conservative policy in this conservative
government could you think of anyone
item that they have actually passed or
proposed to do which is actually
conservative to me it all seems to be
left of Blair I would like to respond to
the first question if I may because that
I think this is terribly important I
entirely agree that there is a at the
heart of conservatism is this idea of
belonging to a community and as it were
responding to that community with
gratitude and a sense of membership and
a sense of duty and this is of course
what blue labor wants to put at the
forefront of its thinking obviously
someone like Maurice Glasman has made a
very impressive
start in doing that so I think I am very
much drawn to that and also drawn to the
idea that that that aspect of the
political Enterprise is can be separated
to a great extent from any commitment to
particular kind of economy although I'm
very much in favor of the free market
I'm very suspicious of the globalized
form of it and the way in which it it
does not respond to the demands of the
local of local communities and local
forms of value so and this is a problem
for real conservatism to develop an
economic doctrine that does not Menace
with the local communities on which we
all depend so and I think blue labor is
doing a great job here
and it is a very much a conservative
movement within the Labour Party and and
they hate it
so it must be good the conservative
policies any my world of I would leave
the real questions about the future of
the party to you I have I think that
there are its there are no conservative
policies that I can immediately call to
mind but except that for the brief time
when Michael Gove was Minister of
Education when he set up the free
schools and and trying to recapture
education from the educationists
which is essentially what needs to be
done to return it to the parents that so
those who really have a sense of
responsibility towards the children I
think actually Michael Gove wherever he
tends to be does perform a radical
conservative shake-up so I think we
should not dismiss them all by any means
and of course much of conservatism on my
view is not about having policies but
about avoiding them you know our
greatest prime minister in my view Lord
Salisbury was in office for 20 years and
nobody can remember him
you know that surely is that the
archetype of the conservative politician
this does play against the natural
instinct of politicians of course I mean
just tie a couple of those together the
I mean it seems to me that there is
already an extraordinary Association
forming mainly you might say in the
north of England but between natural
labour voters or people who were for
long time labour voters and an element
of the Conservative Party or a breakaway
element of it I mean I've been quietly
rejoicing in recent days that the video
is of the change meetings which look
like a sort of carriage clock makers
meeting in a Travelodge hotel which the
various people who are running that
party have to pretend the rallies where
they're not small congregations and
comparing those with these extraordinary
valleys of the brexit party in the north
of England which are genuinely and seem
to be impulsive sort of ground up or
rebellions now I don't know myself I
mean this this will this will be
something we'll all be thinking about in
the months and so on ahead I mean I
desperately like most people want this
country to heal from the brexit debate
and cannot bare us having the brexit
debate for the rest of our lives but if
two parties pretend to offer brexit and
don't then obviously people will go
elsewhere and I think there's an
interesting thing happening which is
that both the main parties are at a
position where they could split in some
significant way over this I don't know
what I feel about that in a way other
than that it is to some extent exciting
that the Conservative Party might not be
able to blackmail us with Jeremy Corbyn
and just say you have to vote for us or
Jeremy Corbyn because I think that the
vote has to matter more than that it
can't just be that the key people I mean
one of the central insights of
conservatism seems to me that people are
loyal to institutions that are loyal to
them
that it's a reciprocal arrangement and
the Conservative Party demands loyalty
of people to whom it shows no loyalty
itself
[Applause]
we've probably got time for one more
Bank of questions they say I've sort of
ignored people in the front of the
latest reasons or anti Lucas reason
doing something maybe there's a
gentleman here as well there's a couple
there and I ask a question to Roger
Scruton about isn't the the public body
that he was fired from fundamentally a
social socialist entity and why would he
want to be part of nationalizing the
concept of beauty outflanking Scruton
from the right the other person here and
then somebody yes lady there and then
the gentleman at the front there's a
promise though the great slogans for
conservatism are probably to be found in
the New Testament do you think that
conservatism or enlightened classical
liberalism is fatally wounded without
Christianity so Douglass best leader of
the Conservative Party treasom a or
Roger Scruton question Roger I'm not
making this up my next event tonight is
being addressed by James Brokaw any
message for him do you want to take them
in I think the first one I would deal
with this isn't it the whole idea of
taking taking hold of the housing market
and turning it in the direction of
beauty isn't that like nationalizing the
idea of beauty and imposing the
dictatorship of the state from above I
think many people have felt that
shouldn't we open open this to the
people and let people build what they
want where they want and how they want
I'm this is this connects very closely
with the question about the
communitarians and blue labor
you can't defend communities simply by
letting
the market loosed upon them I think this
has been this is part of the story of
Europe in the modern world that we've
inherited a very complex civilization
which is to a great extent dependent
upon legislation from above and
dependent upon a culture of of knowledge
and expertise which isn't necessarily
well available to everyone you travel
around France and you you visit these
beautiful towns and villages and you ask
yourself a question you know how
wonderful that these things exist how
did it happen
it didn't happen just because people
builds like that it happened because
people believed in the place they were
building and also believed in
controlling each other to make sure that
individuals didn't spoil those places
and that is was the spirit of our
planning law that it came into full
flight after the second world war we are
we have inherited something beautiful
work a wonderful beautiful country and
beautiful towns within it and we must
pass on this inheritance not spoil it
and that means building in the right way
and our planning laws were designed to
achieve that the problem is there's
money to be made out of ugliness and
indeed ugliness is more remunerative
than beauty or has been in recent times
partly because of the collapse of
Education in the architecture schools
the the relentless indeed socialist
propaganda of architectural modernists
saying that you know we must build for
the people and build without all these
fancy ornaments and all these luxuries
at the that the middle class are looking
for building concrete and steel and
glass in straight lines and then shove
the buggers into it and that was the
post-war policy and that's how I see
socialism in this market not as a not as
a gesture of freedom but the wrong kind
of control question is to get the right
kind of control and and one
is harmonious with the free the free
market in individual properties very
hard that was what I was thinking about
but there we are I think we should
finish on the Christianity question but
I may be the gentle at the front
obviously Roger Scruton over trees are
may for Prime Minister although I would
ask for portfolio in the cabinet and I
was at something with Andrew Roberts the
other day where a politician sort of
said to Andrew Roberts
well of course let's say that and
Roberts is Prime Minister and Andrew
very generously said the first thing I
do is make Douglas Minister for culture
and public enlightenment and I said and
war we agreed this is a very good new
portfolio which I would also I'd also
asked him the first part of the Scruton
administration the lady raises an
incredibly important question we
actually haven't got around to this
evening the role of Christianity in our
culture
we're obviously coming apart from it or
away from it but we don't know what
we're going to what's well it can't
we're we have inherited from the
Enlightenment the idea that that
religion is essentially a private affair
even if we do have this formal official
religion in this country it is not
imposed upon us in any particularly
emphatic way but it's the legacy of
thinking of feeling and of moral being
it's still there with us and it's
inherited by all our institutions and
the attempt to dispense with it does
hollow out those institutions leave them
spiritually vacant and it's up to people
of faith to try and fill them again and
you can only do that from your own heart
you can't do that by asking a minister
to impose it for you and my view is that
Christians are called to do this and the
more Christians they are there are the
more likely it is that it will happen
and that's why I think one shouldn't do
spare you know we're in the same
situation as the Christians in the
catacombs and we have to keep the light
burning down there
TS Eliot is somebody who's always
mattered a great deal to both of us I
think we've both credited him with a lot
of our own spark perhaps one might say I
always think of that that passage in the
four quartets what did he tells us that
what there is left to discover by
strength and Submission has already been
discovered once or twice or several
times by men whom one cannot hope to
emulate mmm but there is no competition
there is only the fight to recover what
has been lost and found and lost again
and again and now under conditions that
seem unpropitious but perhaps neither
gain nor loss for us there is only the
trying the rest is not our business I
think probably the the clock tells us
it's 8:30 which point women to finish
speaking but is there anything that's on
your mind that we haven't covered or no
not really
just everything else but thank you to
the audience for being so sympathetic
yes I think I don't say just thank you
to you because there are quite a lot of
things you can do in London on Wednesday
choose evening will choose evening yeah
mmm
Tuesday and for us at any rate to see
you all here it means an enormous amount
and I think in itself is a sign of great
hope because it shows how many people
care about ideas and about conservatism
and about the culture and so I had any
rate would like to finish by thanking
you and wish you all a very good night
[Applause]
you